une voiture criblée d'impacts de balles
entouré par des traces de sang et des
débris voici les images communiquées par
les médias iraniens après l' attaque qui
a coûté la vie à un scientifique
travaillant sur le programme nucléaire
de téhéran
selon le ministère de la défense de la
république islamique
il s'agit de mohsen fariza des chefs du
département recherche & innovation du
ministère ce dernier a été gravement
blessé par plusieurs assaillants alors
qu'il se trouvait dans son véhicule
hiller ensuite succombé à ses blessures
pour le chef de la diplomatie iranienne
cette attaque a été organisée par israël
des terroristes ont assassiné
aujourd'hui un éminent scientifique
iranien
cette lâcheté avec des indications
sérieuses du rôle d'israël montre le
bellicisme désespérée de ses auteurs de
son côté le chef d'état-major iranien
promet de vengeance terrible aux auteurs
du meurtre sans mentionner l'état hébreu
même si ces accusations sont impossibles
à vérifier le nom de mohsen fakhrizadeh
a déjà été mentionné par le premier
ministre israélien
il y a deux ans benyamin nétanyahou
l'avait qualifié de père du programme
d'armement nucléaire iranien
ce meurtre s'ajoute à une longue liste
de scientifiques iraniens spécialisée
dans le domaine nucléaire assassiner des
morts que la république islamique
attributs systématiquement israël
ce nouveau meurtre intervient également
à moins de deux mois avant l'accession
du démocrate joe biden à la maison
blanche le président élu américain a
annoncé qu'il adopterait une posture
différente vis-à-vis de l'iran après la
politique intransigeante de donald trump
ce dernier a choisi de retirer en 2018
les états unis de l'accord sur le
programme nucléaire de téhéran
jobs hayden a lui annoncé vouloir
proposer à l'iran une voix crédible de
retour à la diplomatie